you're thinking about running across the
country
in in a challenge you call the
transcontinental run
can you describe this challenge and what
the heck you're thinking yeah
yeah so this is uh you know one thing
that is exciting about ultra marathons i
think in a lot of places especially
early in someone's ultra marathon
adventure if they decide to do that
as a you know part of their life is you
have like these early years where you're
doing things for the first time
and it's like so cool and scary at the
same time to think
today i'm gonna run 100 miles and the
first ever run before is 50
or something like that and you just know
you're gonna do something that you've
never done before you're gonna
experience things you would have never
been able to predict
uh and it's like this really interesting
unique
like human experience i think so for me
i spent most of my career at this point
like doing i got through that phase in a
lot of the events i'm really interested
in
and then it was like now let's repeat it
and see if we can do it better and you
get into that mindset for a while which
is
also a fun mindset but there is that
kind of like uh
desire to kind of have that a human
experience again of like
you know not knowing what could happen
or is this doable type of a thing but
still doing it and figuring it out along
the way so i would describe the trans
continental project as something like
that it's
not anything unique to me or anything
new there's been a lot of people who've
done it before
uh but essentially it's a route uh
there's different routes there's one
kind of main one that's done for like
the that is used as the record route
more or less that you go from
san francisco to new york and
essentially you live out of an rv
uh while you're running so you run as
much as you can during the day then you
go to bed at night
and then you get up and do it again and
you're you're handling all the logistics
and the
process of trying to make sure you can
get up the next day and do again what
you did the day before which is gonna be
the biggest difference so
for me i've done all single day ultra
marathons where
you're gonna ring yourself dry at
knowing the next day or week or however
long you need you're going to be able to
just kind of like shut everything down
and let them catch back up whereas with
this
like you know you're doing it again and
again again yeah and you know the record
is by a guy named pete costner who
averaged just over 72 miles a day
finished in 42 days six hours and 30
minutes and i mean just like
72 miles 73 miles and then like
next day again next day again just
knowing every day when you finish you
spend a whole day running
and then okay i'm gonna go to bed i'm
gonna wake up in the morning i'm gonna
have to do this again
and then you know have that happen for
six weeks and that's if it goes very
well
so luck i assume is a big part of this
yeah for sure i mean there's just so
many variables that are uncontrollable
on this type of an experience just
because i mean you go over the sierras
maybe you hit a storm
you know you try to time it most people
do it in start in september so you
can get over the mountain passes without
a big storm coming through
uh but also get to the east coast before
it's like the middle of winter
so like september early september start
is kind of ideal
uh but you can you know i mean pete was
very fortunate from a weather standpoint
i think he made one big mistake we had a
little too aggressive in the beginning
had to take a full day off so he
actually averaged from a moving day
standpoint closer to 75 miles per day um
but yeah i mean there's going to be
things that i can't prepare for won't
know
it's going to happen and you know a lot
of that will get a lot of the logistical
stuff will get leaned on with the crew
so that's i mean that's the hardest part
right now is just like
getting all that put together where it's
like okay i need to have the rv ready i
need to have all the stuff and we need
to have
the places figured out where we're going
to stop and and the people that
can you know dedicate that much time to
an
activity like that you know there's a
lot of moving parts even before you
start the adventure itself when are you
you're taking the san francisco to new
york right yeah and when are you doing
the
the run september 1st is when uh you
know barring anything like catastrophic
between now and then it's really
exciting but i mean it's incredible so
you
you'll probably have a bunch of people
just randomly running with you are
people going to be tracking where you're
located
yeah so i'll be documenting everything
because i mean my hope is that i'm doing
it primarily to raise awareness for
fight for the forgotten justin ren's
charity
uh but with that said i think i am
capable of uh
if i have a good experience uh you know
chasing the record or going after the
record or
at least getting close to it so oh
so you're gonna try to beat this record
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna go out with the
i'm gonna structure
the process in a way that leaves that
door open is the way i would describe it
i'm gonna try not to do anything
that would potentially put it in a
situation where
that becomes the primary goal just
because i want to make sure that the
reason i decided to do the first place
was fight for the forgotten so i want to
make sure that i don't end up
two-thirds way across the country with a
broken leg and like
hey guys uh i guess the donation
button's turned off
[Laughter]
so focus on like don't sacrifice that
right
that goal but also there's a community
aspect to it
that i feel like are you going to
i mean so you're going to document and
post yeah
but are you going to also is there a
safety perspective here it's like the
forest gump thing
you might have large numbers of crowds
that run along with you for a while
yeah worried about that kind of thing i
wouldn't say i'm worried about i mean i
think there's probably
there's remote enough spots along the
way where you'll get some alone time
more
more likely i don't necessarily mind if
people want to jump in there
there'll be some people that will
definitely want to do that and and they
can come in and
but the reality is like it's probably
not going to be a scenario where there's
like
you know 40 people following me at all
times
you say that now yeah you never know
just wait for this podcast
yeah and then if joe finds out you're
doing this then we're really in trouble
all right so uh i mean what are the
things that you think will be the
hardest
for you and also like how do you train
for this kind of thing
um and what yeah what are the hardest
things you anticipate how do you train
for them
yeah so the way i'm looking at this is
it's much less about performance from
the traditional sense
where i need to be able to be x fit
i think i need to be injury proof that's
what's going to be a
detriment if you think about it like if
i manage to average
nine minute mile pace for a day
that would be 80 miles in a 12 hour time
frame so i'll easily have 12 hours of
moving time per day
9 minute pace i think is slow enough
that it's not an unreasonable clip
so like when you i mean obviously
there's things that slow you down or
i'll probably take walking breaks you
know stopping breaks you got to
stay on top of nutrition that's the
other big thing too i'm probably eating
like anywhere between 10 to 15 000
calories a day which is you know i could
probably count on my hand a couple of
occasions where i've eaten that much
in my life so now i got to do that for
six plus weeks in a row
and you don't want any having any
stomach problems your friends are trying
to minimize
the amount of stomach problems so you
would you estimate about 12 to 13 to 14
hours of running every day yeah that's
probably like from from the
first step to the last step it'll
probably be somewhere around like say 14
hours 13 hours or something like that
would be a pretty good estimate
and then getting rest and so and then
minimizing the risk of injury which
could be as small as like
like literally uneven surfaces resulting
to like
stepping the wrong way i mean that's
going to be a lot of steps
yeah yeah uh-huh so the probability of
injury are you worried about that kind
of stuff
is it can you strengthen the ankles or
those kinds of things that prevent
yeah possibility of injury and that's
that's where i'm putting a lot of my
focus in
is uh i think like just being running
fit is gonna be like generally speaking
is gonna be
important i'm going to i think just from
a lifetime of running is going to be a
huge advantage
a lot of these like kind of like
mechanical movements are going to be
very established it's just going to be
about can i tolerate that volume of it
there i think i'm doing more strength
work i think this is something where
it's like
you know maybe adding five pounds of
lower body muscle is going to be an
advantage versus a disadvantage when
you're looking at power weight ratio
because i just don't really don't i
don't i
never need to be running a 648 mile for
this adventure
um and i so i'm looking at that i'm
doing a lot more of that stuff focusing
on that
the training is changing a fair bit
where
it's more polarizing versus kind of
being i mean i've always had some
polarization in my training but this is
even to an extreme where like i'm gonna
do some simulations where
uh you know i go out and do two or three
days where i target
the exact thing i will be doing on the
trans con you were on instagram posting
about these simulated runs so you
legitimately like trying to perfectly
copy what would happen
one two or three day segment on that
right yeah just to kind of
start to weed out where are the
potential problems
so let's say i do a two or three day
simulation where i'm averaging 70 miles
a day and i find out at the end of three
days there's a really weak spot here
um i need to address that or i need to
find a way to make that not a weak spot
i think that's the only way to really
get as close as you can to avoiding
injury
have you done that yet have you done a
two day sony month like even that's
incredibly difficult i haven't yet i'm
going to build up to it because that's
the other thing too is like
i don't think you want to be so
aggressive with that where you get
injured
trying to figure out how not to get
injured uh so i'll all
what i'm gonna start what i just started
last week is i've
uh it looks really weird on my training
schedule because like last week i ran
almost 150 miles but i took two days off
so it's like
usually for me to get to 150 miles
that's a seven day training week
uh so that's the way i'm doing it like i
did i did a day where i did uh
you know two like just over 20 milers
separated with by just a couple hours
and within a couple hours i did like a
three
three mile walk the following morning i
woke up and ran i think it was like just
over 36 miles first thing in the morning
just to get an idea of just like kind of
like what is it like to be i mean this
was in phoenix too so it was 100 degrees
for the majority of that
to suffer then rest yeah suffer again
how that feels there's enough precedent
with this sort of an
activity where like everyone i've talked
to so far has told me like there is
going to be
like this kind of like gradual decline
in the early stages where you're just
like okay it's getting worse it's
getting worse it's getting worse
and you hit a point where you're just
like it hits kind of rock bottom
and then like it starts to kind of
gradually improve so you kind of have to
let yourself
get it it's weird i think i can maybe
eliminate i'm trying to find a way to
eliminate some of that by
doing the simulations whereas i from
what i've seen i haven't seen a lot of
people do the simulation route yet
i've seen people just do like a lot of
training and then say like okay i'll
spend the first
seven to ten days adapting to this and
then i'll get comfortable
within this environment and be fine
whereas i'm going to try to get to a
point where like
some of that is already kind of cleared
up before i start but not so much that
i'm like adding like an extra essential
week to the trip
worth of running what what what do you
think will be the hardest simulator run
leading up to like will you do three
days yeah i think i'll probably try to
do three days
somewhere between 70 and 80 miles each
will be kind of like the goal
uh maybe in august do you think how
close to yeah i would like it to be in
august like early august would be ideal
i think like maybe the first week in
august because that gives me kind of
three weeks to let things kind of settle
down from that
but then it's crazy this is incredible
it's
it's actually interesting because like
if i did let's say i did the simulation
now
um the problem with that is like the
adaptations from just like the breakdown
and the strengthening would likely be
gone unless i did it again
uh so i want to inch up to it so that
like
and get close enough to the starting
date so that i'm still kind of like
you know holding on to that adaptation
when i start it
so then those first few days maybe
aren't quite as miserable and you said
uh
if everything goes amazing and you're
challenging the record it'll be like a
42 day run
yeah so that's what the record is almost
exactly six weeks and that's at seventy
two and a half miles per day so will you
be posting online and like
yeah instagram's gonna be a big one i
think i might do a few like youtube
stuff along the way too
um yeah i'm still ironing out exactly
how much i think
at minimum i'll do i'll do some
instagram stuff i think i'll go live on
instagram a few times during the day
when i take like walking breaks
uh partly just to kind of i think
keeping people in
i mean it stays true to the the goal of
raising awareness but it also i find
when you bring people in there is an
added pressure to that
but there's also this sense that i've
learned from the treadmill experience
since we had like
a pretty big production for that in the
sense that i mean as much as you can
turn on a camera in your own house but
like
the i remember thinking we had like 30
people lined up to come in and guest
speak during that
and there was points of that where i was
like you know you get that voice we
talked about the beginning where it's
like you know
maybe you could quit like do you really
need to run 100 miles on a treadmill is
this really going to be valuable for you
yeah and then you think about oh you
know what there's uh you know courtney
dewalter one of the best female
ultrarunners to ever
exist is taken in 30 minutes to an hour
out of her day
to come on in two hours to you know help
me you know amplify this event and do i
really want to be sending emails out to
these people saying hey guys i know you
were gracious enough to
block out time of your day you know i
think there's a little bit of that to do
where you're like you're
you're jumping in with the community
that is following along and saying
here's how things are going
show them the best the worst and
everything between and then ultimately
have that hold you accountable a little
bit too it's like
hard to get up in the morning and not go
back out i don't know how you are but i
had to uh whenever i did any kind of
physical stuff
like the 48 hour challenge or just any
kind of running
i hated turning on the camera i
hated it like because you have to like
smile and be friendly and stuff
oh i'm just gonna be super miserable if
i'm miserable
well that's it so like exactly in some
sense that's what people
you know we're gonna get a happy zac or
an angry exactly it's like you're making
bets
and i'm sure there'll be some days maybe
not many maybe very few where you're
truly happy with yourself
like for some weird ecstatic reason
maybe
if you get over the hump whatever that
you mentioned that this dip
i mean it's it's fascinating how many
how much suffering this actually entails
i wonder well and one thing i'm gonna
definitely try to leverage to my
advantage
and one of the reasons why i think fight
for the forgotten was the charity that
really triggered me to decide to do this
the transcontinental
route was something i learned about
early in my ultra running career
and i thought to myself i want to do
that someday but it was one of those
kind of
far-off distance things that it never
really like actualized in your mind
until you put a date down or
you know mention it on the joe rogan
experience or something like that
and then it's like people want to know
when is this happening and uh
um you know what i try to think about is
you know the reason justin identified
the pygmy tribe
was because they were super forgotten
where you know
we think about just like some of these
third world countries where
it's a scenario of like some people it's
easy for us
here in the us to think to ourselves
well why don't they just industrialize
why don't they just like you know
start to innovate a bit why are they so
primitive what's wrong with them
in reality like when you take uh when
you scale things down to the degree
where
you need the entire day because of the
situation you're in
just to take care of your basic needs of
water and food
you never get the opportunity to even
build a real
like establishment or you know build on
that
like you need you need the free time or
you need a portion of your population to
have the free time available to innovate
and the pygmy tribe just hadn't had that
historically in fact they weren't even
considered humans by like the local
government for quite some time and
you know the people that really pay the
price in some of these situations are
the women because they're the ones that
get saddled with like the water
gathering and things like that so the
reason that justin picked wells
to build was because he thought to
himself if we can get them wells
then now these women don't spend all day
walking and carrying water
now they can just get that water and now
we have half the population freed up for
other things now maybe they can start
farms
they can build some housing and stuff
like that and it just it
exponentially improves once you take
care of some of those big
key early things so when i'm thinking
about like
you know do i really need to go out here
and travel another 12 hours a day my
mind's gonna hopefully go to
well if one of those women woke up in
the pygmy tribe one morning decided you
know what do i really need to go get
water today
well yeah you do you really do have to
yeah you're running for that
yeah and that that will give you fuel
hopefully but
yeah yeah i mean the reality is always
there where i don't have to do it like
they do
have to do it so you know but i think
just keeping that perspective
it it puts us back to the beginning
where it's this is one of those
situations where i think it's like
uh a no-quit situation you have to put
yourself in a no-quit situation here
because it's
uh you know it's just bigger than you i
can't wait to see like the dark places
you go
i mean there's some yeah the the quit
situations
and hopefully we get to have a glimpse
of those because i think those are
really inspiring
when somebody is uh both gets broken by
them
because you know how tough you are but
also it's almost broken and overcomes it
i mean that's just fascinating stories i
can't wait
you